And for young,
those were equivalent in some sense to the loss gods.
And so for young,
your,
your interest was being manipulated behind the scenes by unseen forces that were
associated with your character or logical development across time.
That was the manifestation of the self.
So the self is this,
the,
the potential you,
let's say,
and the way it operates in the present is by gripping your interest in directing
it somewhere.
And that's part of the instinct of self realization.
It's a mind boggling idea,
man.
Really it's,
I think it's correct.
I,
I can't see how it can't be correct.
It doesn't mean I understand it completely,
but it certainly seems phenomenologically correct.
And I mean,
the potential that you are has to manifest itself somehow in the here and now.
It has to.
And what better way than by directing your attention,
you know,
it's like,
it seems like this might be useful for you or maybe you get attracted to this
person.
Maybe you admire this person that happens with kids a lot.
They'll admire someone and then copy them.
And you can see that that's obviously part of their developmental progression,
right?
It's a form of hero worship,
but kids are very imitative and they hear a worship at the drop of a hat,
and so they're,
they're entranced by the,
the next stage of development.
And if they see someone who embodies that,
especially if it's in the zone of proximal development,
it's,
it's some,
it's something they could achieve stretching a bit.
They find someone who embodies that next stage of development and then they
start to imitate them and act like the,
well,
we're adults are no different.
We're no different.
We're just,
we do it at a perhaps more abstracted,
sophisticated level.